him meanwhile in social justice warrior
land also a san francisco
high school has decided to rename itself
so san francisco is according to the uk
daily mail
decided to rename abraham lincoln high
school
and you're saying yourself wait isn't
abraham lincoln the president who uh
freed their lives
like civil war guy abraham lincoln like
not some other abraham lincoln i've
never heard of
oh yeah no no it's that abraham lincoln
but he's bad now san francisco is going
to rename
abraham lincoln high school because the
former president did not demonstrate
that black lives
mattered to him
i'm pretty sure they did considering
that he fought a civil war to end
slavery
that seems like a pretty good indicator
that somebody is kind of concerned about
black lives that he didn't want them to
remain enslaved
but apparently not good enough for the
san francisco woke
also the lococrats at the san francisco
unified school district
they've decided not only to rename the
abraham lincoln high school
because of his treatment of indigenous
peoples through the 1862 homestead act
and the pacific railway act
but also but also they are going to
rename
a bunch of other schools 44 schools will
be renamed
what are these schools george washington
will be renamed of course because george
washington was a slave holder
yes of course george washington was also
the father of the country but you know
you know the people in san francisco
they're better than he is than he was as
a person they just they
if they had lived in 1790 they would
have been better people than george
washington they're the greatest people
who have ever lived
herbert hoover high school is going to
be renamed
that's going to be renamed for some
unspecified reason that i can't exactly
explain
thomas edison will be renamed because
thomas edison was bad
and also dianne feinstein's name will be
stripped
from the dianne feinstein elementary
school for once allowing the confederate
flag to fly
outside city hall so dianne feinstein is
not woken up for this game
it's going to be fun i am looking
forward to in like 10 years when they
have to strip barack obama's name off of
things
because when he started his presidency
he wasn't pro same-sex marriage
like that's going to be fun that will be
enjoyable so they're stripping
all names off all things this is just
marxism it is just
commie bull crap but again this earns
you
you you have now seen history through
the eyes of the oppressed
and this means that we have to take away
all the good things that have happened
in history and we have to
smear them through the mud and this is
going to make the world a better place
speak the language speak and repeat and
if you don't speak
and repeat this means that you're a bad
person
this means that you cannot be among us
the woke
the cadre of the of the brilliant
moral arbiters of the future of the
united states speak and repeat
and by the way you can be just as
sensitive as you want but if you make a
mistake they'll come after you so
here is an example shawn mendes okay so
shawn mendes
uh is uh apparently some sort of a
singer i i
as you well know i am not a follower of
today's pop culture other than being a
platinum award-winning rap artist
um shawn mendes i had to apologize to
sam smith so sam smith is a singer he is
a gay man
he also recently declared himself gender
fluid and said he wanted
to use the terms they and them to refer
to him
which is silly because he's an
individual human being also
he's not changed his biology he remains
a gay man nonetheless
being a gender fluid being right being a
a magical unicorn
sam smith was now owed an apology by by
sean mendez why because sean mendes
committed the egregious sin of saying he
now i know most americans most people
around the world actually look at that
and they're like what now
and that dude and yes that is a dude sam
smith
but if you say that he is a dude he gets
very angry apparently
and if you wish to be welcomed into the
halls of social power you have to abide
by the graces of the language
so sean mendes put out a statement oh
sam smith i'm so sorry for referring
to fs to you as a he for your jingle
bell introduction
it absolutely slipped my mind won't
happen again no apostrophe
sending you so much love also you
absolutely are one of the funniest
people
i've ever met two hearts wow i mean that
is an egregious sin when you call a man
he
not even a man who identifies as a woman
just a man who identifies as a they
as a genderless being when you call him
he
grave grave sin these are our cultural
arbiters
i can't the backlash to this stuff is
going to be overwhelming and it should
be overwhelming it is bad
okay it is it is not good for the
country it is
it is not good for the future of reason
and decency
it's bad stuff did you know that every
like on this video
creates one additional leftist tier
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button